political contributors terry sullivan
and joel payne join us from washington
d.c
terry was the campaign manager for
senator marco rubio's presidential
campaign and joel
is the former director of african
american advertising for hillary
clinton's presidential campaign
good morning to you both i think none of
us will miss the long-winded speeches
but those sort of electric moments that
you usually get with a crowd at
conventions will be absent
joel let me start with you what do the
democrats need to accomplish
in this virtual convention
well anthony you also have to remember
too these are organizing moments and
opportunities
when you're in a state like wisconsin
that's so critical to democrats winning
not just having the pomp and
circumstance of the convention but
actually having the opportunity to be on
the ground
to get activists excited and revved up
for the election coming up the
republicans will have the same challenge
next week with their convention i think
what's also going to look different here
is the keynote normally the keynote is
the big elevated opportunity moment
for a young rising leader like a barack
obama in 2004 or like a sarah palin for
the
republicans in 2008. it's going to be
different this year they're going to be
a collection of democratic voices on
wednesday
so there'll be some things that look
similar but a lot of things that'll look
very different
terry you've run a presidential campaign
how would you feel about having a
virtual convention for your candidate
you know in many ways there are a lot of
obvious challenges but but one of the
biggest
advantages is that as a campaign manager
in a big event like this you're trying
to limit risk you're trying to mitigate
any of the unforeseeable things that can
happen protesters or
you know someone falling off stage or
any of these things
and this removes a lot of that look i've
been in a situation where we've
literally had staff bribe a train
conductor
just to not blow his whistle when he
went past a live venue so there's a lot
going in that a live venue
and something big like this really does
make an extra challenge
and and this moves a lot of that
especially when you've got a candidate
like joe biden
who tends to be gaff prone and is rusty
because he hasn't been out there
campaigning in the last four months
so in many ways this is an advantage for
his campaign yeah someday you'll have to
tell me how that conversation with the
train conductor went
i wanted to ask you a former ohio
republican governor john kasich is going
to speak
speak at the democratic convention in
support of joe biden there's also
supposedly
another prominent republican who's going
to come out for that what's the sign
for biden what's the significance of
that do you think terry
not much i mean look john kasich is
always about john kasich and always has
been it's rather rich
since no other republican did more to
help
donald trump get the nomination than
john kasich did to serve as a spoiler by
staying in the race as long as he did
uh you know he's just doing it to get
try to extend
his his time in the limelight um but
it's no significance whatsoever
for uh for joe biden joel our cbs news
battleground tracker poll
i found an overwhelming majority of
democrats are glad that
that uh biden picked kamala harris what
do you think that choice
uh represents for the future of the
party
well i've been saying that this uh
choice is as much about 2024 and 2028 as
it is about 2020.
it shows where the party is going and it
also shows that there is a
new generation of democratic leaders
that joe biden is really
serving his kind of the the ushering
endpoint for he wants to
he wants to demonstrate that it's not
just going to be kind of politics as
usual for democrats that there are going
to be
new voices in the party that he's going
to help elevate what's interesting about
kamala harris is
she can be sold to all parts of the
democratic coalition progressives
women college-educated women in the
suburbs african-americans immigrants
and we're going to see a lot of that on
display this week terry the the
president is digging in on his stance on
mail-in voting do you think that's an
effective strategy
you know i don't but you know when when
is the president listen to anyone
on political advice at the end of the
day republicans do very well
with absentee voting seniors tend to
vote republican
especially in a state like florida where
republicans over perform consistently in
presidential elections
when it comes to mail-in voting or
absentee voting
so it is very very counterproductive to
try to
suppress absentee voting it really is
infuriating terry sullivan joel payne
thank you both very much